हेलो एवरीवन एंड वेरी गुड इवनिंग टू ऑल तो
सबसे पहले आप मुझे य बता सबको मेरी
आवाज सुनाई दे रही है आई एम लाउड एंड
क्लियर प्लीज चैट में जल्दी से बता
दीजिए ओके ऑल क्लियर थैंक
यू कैसे हो आप सब लोग
फाइन ना सभी अच्छे हो और शायद आप लोग
क्लास एंजॉय कर रहे होंग या हेलो मान सिंह
शर्मा
हेलो थोड़ा सा वेट करते हैं दो से तीन
मिनट का बाकी स्टूडेंट्स को भी जवाइन होने
देते
हैं मैं भी बढ़िया हूं परने आई एम आल्सो
फाइन
तब तक के लिए अगर आपका कोई सवाल है तो
मुझसे पूछ सकते हैं रिलेटेड टू प्रीवियस
क्लास तो सबको स् स्टग एनालिसिस करना आ
गया जो लास्ट क्लास में हमने सीखा था कि
स्टग
एनालिसिस कैसे करते हैं क्या होता है सबको
क्लियर
है
एवरीवन तब तक के लिए मैं अपनी मशीन को ऑन
कर लेता हूं तब तक आप लोग जवाइन हो जाइए
ओके
देर ओनली 13 स्टूडेंट
नथ तो आप लोग मुझे बताइए अभी मुझे क्या
करना चाहिए
अभी भी 15 स्टूडेंट हुए
हैं आज का जो सीटीएफ है उसका नाम है एजेंट
सूडो जो आपके टाइटल में लिखा हुआ है
बट एट अब एजेंट सुडो जो सीटीएफ है इसको
सॉल्व तो हम कर लेंगे कोई इशू नहीं है एक
दिन में क्या एक आधे घंटे में हो जाएगा बट
मेरा मोटिव यह है कि आप लोग सीटीएफ को एक
टेक्निक के साथ सॉल्व कर पाए सीटीएफ के
बेस पर मैं आपको टेक्निक्स और उसके जो
रिलेटेड टू जो फंडामेंटल्स है या जो भी
टूल्स आते हैं उनको एक्सप्लेन करता हूं
इसलिए आज का सीटीएफ हमने पार्ट में डिवाइड
किया
कि आज का सीटीएफ आज कंप्लीट नहीं होगा दिस
इ द पार्ट वन बिकॉज इससे रिलेटेड कुछ
कांसेप्ट आएंगे बीच में जिनको मैं
एक्सप्लेन करूंगा तो सीटीएफ एक जरिया है
जिसके थ्रू हम क्या कर सकते हैं अपने
फंडामेंटल को क्लियर कर सकते हैं एवरीवन
क्लियर किसी को कोई दिक्कत तो नहीं है
इसमें हां वेट कर लेते
हैं यह एजेंट सूडो है
दिस इज आवर एजेंट
सूडो नाउ अभी हम इसमें कुछ भी नहीं करने
वाले दे टोटल फाइव टास्क बट अभी हम क्या
करते हैं मशीन को स्टार्ट कर देते हैं तब
तक के लिए
एंड नाउ वी सक्सेसफुली कनेक्टेड टू
आवर ओपन
वीपीएन दिस इज आवर वीपीएन टैब
अगर अग हमें चेक करना तो अभी हम चेक कर
सकते
हैं टनल जीरो इज आवर वीपीएन टैब नाउ व
सक्सेसफुली कनेक्टेड आवर वीपीएन एंड तब तक
हमें आईपी एड्रेस भी असाइन हो गया है तो
तब तक के लिए अभी देखते हैं कितने
स्टूडेंट्स और आए हैं दे ओनली 16
स्टूडेंट्स
नहीं एसएमबी स्पेशल कहां है किसने लिखा कि
एसएमबी एन्यूमरेशन स्पेशल है हु टोल्ड यू
कहां लिखा है कि एसएमबी एन्यूमरेशन से
स्पेशल क्यों है कहां पर लिखा मैंने मैं
तो टाइटल में सूडो लिखा एजेंट सुडो और
इसमें एक इंपॉर्टेंट टूल्स है जो बब स्वीट
है थोड़ा उससे पहले छोटा सा कांसेप्ट है
उसको मैं आपको क्लियर करूंगा फंडामेंटल
कांसेप्ट
अगर आपका प्रीमियम है या फ्री वाला है यह
बताइए ब्लैक
वाइपर
बताइए स्टिल देयर आर ओनली 20 स्टूडेंट्स
फ्री वाला फ्री वाले में होते हैं
प्रीमियम होता है तो इट्स
गुड मैं आपका मतलब मैं आपका क्वेश्चन समझ
नहीं पा रहा थोड़ा सा क्लियर लिखि कि आप
मुझसे पूछना क्या चाहते हो पता नहीं जो आप
टाइप करते हो वह यहां तक क्लियर नहीं है
मतलब आप जो मुझसे पूछना चाह रहे हो या जो
यहां पर अपना पॉइंट रखना चाह रहे हो वह
हमारे लिए यहां पर क्लियर नहीं है आई एम
नॉट गेटिंग दिस पॉइंट की क्या मतलब आपका
मतलब क्या पूछना चाह रहे हो या क्या आप
बताना चाह रहे हो
अभी भी 19 ही स्टूडेंट्स हैं आप ही बताइए
मैं क्या
करूं यहां पर कितने लोग हैं जो एंड्राइड
पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग सीखना चाहते
हैं कितने स्टूडेंट्स हैं जो
एंड्र एप्लीकेशंस हैकिंग जिसको बोल सकते
हैं व सीखना चाहते हैं
नॉट फ्री
पेड अब
बताना एक दिन पहले ही ग्रुप में
था कल से ग्रुप में है
यह हां एसएमबी एमिशन में स्पेशल है ना
वहां पर जो भी स्क्रिप्ट है वहां पर जो भी
मॉड्यूल हैं स्पेशल तो है एसएमबी वनटी
क्रिटिकल वनबिल
शुभम शोक ट्रेनिंग चाहिए तो थोड़ा सा और
वेट कर
लीजिए दो
से तीन मंथ का
मैक्स या थोड़ा सा मैक्स फर
मंथ मैक्स या उससे पहले
भी आई विल आई विल
टीच ओके तो क्लास को स्टार्ट करते हैं देर
ओनली 22 स्टूडेंट्स 24 या 25 जो भी है तो
इससे ज्यादा नहीं आएंगे मुझे लगता है
तो अभी स्टार्ट करते हैं
कंटिन्यू तो दिस इज आवर आईपी एड्रेस
10.1.4
5104 दिस इज आवर आईपी एड्रेस तो अब हमारे
पास आईपी एड्रेस है तो फिर से मेरा वही
सवाल है तो आईपी एड्रेस का सबसे पहले मैं
क्या करूंगा मेरे पास एक आईपी एड्रेस है
व्हाट विल बी दवर फर्स्ट स्टेप अब हम सबसे
पहले क्या करेंगे
बताइए बताइए
बताइए यस आप लोग पता चल रहा है ना
धीरे-धीरे
कि मुझे कब कौन सा क्या स्टेप परफॉर्म
करना है कब कौन सा टूल्स कौन सी अप्रोच
फॉलो करनी है यस तो सबसे पहले हम क्या
करने वाले हैं पिंग शिवी
10.10.5 104 एंड टीटीएल वैल्यू इ 63 तो हम
यह भी बता सकते हैं कि एक नक्स मशीन है
विद द हेल्प ऑफ टीटीएल वैल्यू बट वी आर
नॉट श्यर हम श्यर नहीं है तो अभी मुझे यह
बताइए सबसे बेस्ट अप्रोच क्या है कि मुझे
अभी क्या करना है कि नेक्स्ट नेक्स्ट मुझे
इस पे हैकिंग करनी है मेरे पास एक आईपी
एड्रेस है मुझे किसी कंपनी ने इसको पेन
टेस्ट करने के लिए बोला है तो मुझे कहने
का मतलब क्या इसको मुझे हैक करना है तो
व्हाट विल बी आवर नेक्स्ट स्टेप अगला
स्टेप हमारा क्या होगा मैं थोड़ा सा जूम
कर देता हूं आपके सामने
अभी मुझे बताइए कि मुझे एग्जैक्ट कमांड
बताइए किस कमांड के साथ मुझे क्या-क्या
परफॉर्म करना
है या एन मैप यूज करना है तो एन मैप में
क्या क्या करेंगे
हम सबसे पहले हम सूडो एन मैप ओके क्या
क्या हम परफॉर्म
करेंगे यस एक तो हम सर्विस वर्जन डिटेक्शन
करेंगे साथ के
साथ और
और
हाइन डिफॉल्ट स्क्रिप्ट स्कैन कर ले
डिफॉल्ट स्क्रिप्ट स्कैन कर ले कोई इशू
नहीं है सर्विस वर्जन डिटेक्शन हाइन एससी
डिफॉल्ट स्क्रिप्ट
स्कैन ओके उसके
बाद देन उसके बाद हम आईपी इंसर्ट कर देते
हैं ओके देन उसके बाद हम क्या करते हैं
कंट्रोल शिफ्ट व दिस इज आवर आईपी एड्रेस
इतना काफी है अभी के लिए ओके हिट एंटर दिस
इज माय रूट पासवर्ड ओके देखते हैं कि हमें
रिजल्ट्स में क्याक देखने को मिलता है यह
लैब सच में थोड़ी सी इंटरेस्टिंग लैब है
अभी तक जितनी भी लैब हमने परफॉर्म की वे
मतलब कि इतनी इंटरेस्टिंग लैब नहीं थी बस
जस्ट बेसिक बेसिक लैब यह भी है बस थोड़ी
सी इंटरेस्टिंग है थोड़ी स ट्विस्ट है और
थोड़ी सी इंटरेस्टिंग लैब है अभी यहां पर
देखिए हमें जो इंफॉर्मेशन मिली देखिए
पोर्ट 21 इ ओपन एफटीपी पोर्ट है v एस
एफटीपीडी
3.0.3 पोर्ट 22 एएच यह भी ओपन है अभी यहां
पर आरएस एडीएसए की वैल्यू है पोर्ट 80
एटीटीपी अचे
2.4.29 122 उसके बाद एटीटीपी सर्वर हैडर
ये है
क्या करते हैं हम वलने बिलिटी स्कैनिंग
जिससे क्या होगा वो लेटेस्ट वनबिल तो
फाइंड आउट नहीं करता बट जो जेनरिक वनबिल
है उनको क्या करते हैं हम फाइंड आउट करने
की कोशिश करते हैं क्या एजिस्ट करती है या
नहीं करती उसके लिए हम क्या करें सुडो एन
मैप देन उसके
बाद हाइन हाइन
स्क्रिप्ट वलन स्कैन करेंगे ओके वल्नट
स्कन सबको पता है वनटी स्कैन क्या होता
है हाइफ साइफन स्क्रिप्ट इक्वल चाहिए नहीं
हमें वलन स्क ओके देन हिट
एंटर अभी देखते हैं कि इसके बेस पर हमें
क्या इंफॉर्मेशन मिलती है अभी यह वो फेज
है आपका पोर्ट स्कैनिंग सर्विस वर्जन
डिटेक्शन ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम डिटेक्शंस जो
मैंने आपको एनम सेक्शन में सिखाया था ना
आपको कि सर्विस एमेशन सेक्शन या एक्टिव
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग में आपको सिखाया था
सर्विस वर्जन डिक्शन होस्ट डिस्कवरी
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम डिटेक्शंस फायरवॉल
डिटेक्शंस विद द हेल्प ऑफ ए मैप देन एमरे
में मैंने आपको बताया था कि जो भी सर्विस
मिलती है उस सर्विस के बेस पे एफटीपी नमरे
एसएमबी नमेश ए एचटीटीपी एन्यूमरेशन
बेसिकली वी कैन से दैट कि हमारा वेब सर्वर
है वेब सर्वर एन्यूमरेशंस और अभी तक हमने
एसक्यूएल वगैरह देखा नहीं है तो उसके ऊपर
एन्यूमरेशन परफॉर्म नहीं कर रहे या एस एन
एमपी एन्यूमरेशन मैंने आपको बताया था बट
इन बिटवीन कहीं पर आएगा तो हम उसको
एक्सप्लेन करूंगा तो ये सारी की सारी
चीजें अभी आपको परफॉर्म करनी है बट मैं
आपको क्या है कि ज्यादा टाइम ना लगे
क्योंकि
हर एक क्लास में आपको डिटेल्स में
एक्सप्लेन कर चुका हूं तो यह आपकी
रिस्पांसिबिलिटी है यहां पर प्रैक्टिस
करना तो अभी हमें यहां पर क्या मिला कि
देखिए पोर्ट 80 है यह एचटीटीपी सीवी
207 स्क्रिप्ट एग्जीक्यूशन फील्ड ओके एसटी
कुड नॉट सस वलन बिलिटी नहीं है एक्सेस
वनबिल नहीं है और डोम बेस्ड एक्सेस वटी भी
नहीं है लेकिन रिलेटेड टू एफटीपी और एसस
हमें कोई भी इंफॉर्मेशन नहीं तो नेक्स्ट
स्टेप अभी हम क्या करेंगे हमें कुछ खास
इंफॉर्मेशन यहां पर नहीं मिली देन व्ट वी
शुड
डू प्रस आपकी यही रहेगी जब भी आपके पास
कोई भी आईपी एड्रेस रहेगा ओके आपकी अप्रोच
यही
रहेगी बताइए व्ट विल बी अवर नेक्स्ट
स्टेप क्या करेंगे हम अभी अभी हमारे पास
तीन पोर्ट है 21 22 पोर्ट 80 नाउ अभी हमें
और क्या चेक करना चाहिए एज ए बिगनर
क्योंकि मैं आपको पहले भी बता चुका हूं हम
कर चुके हैं अपनी प्रीविस प्रीवियस क्लास
में यस विजिट पोर्ट 8 नेक्स्ट क्या हमें
एफटीपी को चेक नहीं करना चाहिए कि ये
एनोनिमस जो एनोनिमस वलने बिलिटी होती है
एफटीपी एनन जो वलने बिलिटी है उससे
वल्नरेबल है या नहीं है क्या हमें चेक
करना चाहिए तो उसके लिए हम क्या करेंगे
फिर से सुडो एंड मैप उसके बाद हाइन हाइन
स्क्रिप्ट उसके बाद एफटीपी हाइन अननोन
एफटीपी हाइन अननोन देन टारगेट आईपी एड्रेस
ओके अभी चेक कर लेते हैं क्या यह नेबल है
या नहीं
है
नाउ यहां पर तो हमें कुछ भी रिजल्ट नहीं
मिला
हमें कोई भी रिजल्ट नहीं मिला यहां पर बस
सिंपल 21 22 80 दैट
मींस दैट मींस इट इज नॉट वल्नरेबल
टू एनोनिमस लॉगिन इट इज नॉट मिस
तो अभी हमें क्या करना नेक्स्ट स्टेप
व्हाट विल बी अवर नेक्स्ट स्टेप क्या करें
बताइए व्हाट विल बी अवर नेक्स्ट स्टेप अब
हम क्या करेंगे पोर्ट 8 चेक करेंगे
क्योंकि पोर्ट 22 के लिए हमें क्रेडेंशियल
चाहिए और क्रेडेंशियल हमें ब्रूट फोर्स
करने पड़ेंगे बट अभी तक हमारे पास एक यूजर
नेम तक नहीं है जिनको हम ब्रूट फोर्स
ट्राई करेंगे ओके तो नाउ फर्स्ट ऑफ ऑल हम
क्या चेक करते हैं पट चेक करते कंट्रोल
शिफ्ट व और हिट
एंटर दिस इज आवर पोर्ट एटी यह क्या
इंफॉर्मेशन मिली यहां
पर डियर
एजेंट यूज योर ओन कोड नेम एज यूजर एजेंट
टू एक्सेस द साइट फ्रॉम एजेंट
आर फ्रॉम एजेंट आर ट्स इट चलो अभी हम राइट
क्लिक करते हैं व्यू पेज सोर्स देखते हैं
पर कुछ है नहीं हमें यहां पर भी कुछ देखने
को नहीं मिला इट्स क्लीन तो यहां पर हमारे
पास कुछ भी नहीं है ना ओके अभी हम रोबोट
एक्सटी चेक कर लेते
हैं रोबोट डटी एक्सटी हम चेक कर लेते हैं
य रहा ओके आई एम सॉरी फॉर ट यह क्या कर
दिया हमने
रोबोट डटी
एक्सटी तो रोबोट डटी एक्सटी फाइल भी नहीं
है तो अभी हमारे पास फिर से एक समस्या आन
खड़ी हुई यह एक विपदा है बोल सकते समस्या
है कि अभी हम क्या करें व्हाट विल बी आवर
नेक्स्ट स्टेप सोर्स कोड में कुछ नहीं है
रोबोट डटी एक्सटी फाइल नहीं है तो अभी हम
क्या
करेंगे कि डी एजेंट इसको समझने की कोशिश
करो डियर एजेंट यूज योर ओन कोड नेम एज
यूजर एजेंट टू एक्सेस द साइट फ्रॉम एजेंट
आर क्या डायरेक्ट बट फोर्स ट्राई करें एक
बार शल व ट्राई डायरेक्टरी बट
फोर्सिंग सही रहेगा आप लोगों के लिए बताइए
कोड नेम एज यूजर नेम कर सकते हैं नहीं
नहीं नहीं नहीं अभी आपको क्लियर बोला कि
यूज योर ओन कोड नेम चलो हम एक काम करते
हैं एक बार डरबस्टर का यूज करते हैं
डायरेक्टली बड फोर्स करने के लिए वहां से
हमें क्या इंफॉर्मेशन मिलती
है डरबस्टर हिट
एंटर क्या हमें कोई वैल्यू इंफॉर्मेशन
मिलती भी है या नहीं मिलती है तो
एचटीटीपी यहां पर टारगेट आईपी क्या है
10.10
4514 देन एज इट इज यहां पर हमें क्या करना
है डाउनलोड के अंदर नहीं हमारी लिस्ट होगी
नो यहां पर हमारी वर्ड लिस्ट नहीं है नाउ
गो बैक नहीं हो ग यहां पर यही डायरेक्टरी
2.3 मीयम एकटी अ यही व लिस्ट सिलेक्ट करते
हैं क्योंकि हमारे पास और कुछ भी ऑप्शन
नहीं है और हम स्कैन स्टार्ट करते हैं ये
सबको पता है
ट और रिजल्ट देखते हैं यस इक्सड
पीएपी
आइकन √2
100 ओके
तो तब जब तक ब्रूट फोर्स ट्राई कर रहे हैं
तब तक मैं आपको स्लाइड पर ले चलता हूं एक
वेरी इंटरेस्टिंग कांसेप्ट है जो मैं आपको
बताऊंगा आप लोग लगेगा कि सर आप यह हमें
क्या पढ़ा रहे हो यह हमारे काम का नहीं है
बट यह काफी रेलीवेंट कांसेप्ट है जो आपको
पता होना चाहिए देखिए ओके तो चलिए हम
स्लाइड पर चलते हैं तब तक ब्रूट फोर्स
होने देते हैं सीखते हैं कांसेप्ट क्लियर
करते हैं
चले स्लाइड पर
बताइए मे भी थोड़ा सा बोरिंग हो सकता आप
लोगों के लिए बट मेरे साथ बने रहिए मतलब
आपको एक अच्छा फंडामेंटल स्पॉट मिलेगा तो
हम क्या करते हैं गो टू आवर
स्लाइड देखो फिर से हमारे पास एक कंफ्यूजन
है कि व्ट वी ड इन दिस सिचुएशन यह सिचुएशन
हमारे पास आई है कौन सी जब हमने पोर्ट ए
को विजिट किया तो वहां पर कुछ लिखा हुआ था
बट उसके बाद क्या देखिए यह था कुछ इस तरी
का कोड था डियर एजेंट यूज योर ओन कोड नेम
कोड्स एज यूजर एजेंट टू एक्सेस द साइट ओके
देखो यह एक एप्लीकेशन है जो किसी एक
पर्टिकुलर सर्विस को यूज कर रही है फॉर
एग्जांपल पोर्ट 8 को यूज कर रही है एक
वेबसाइट है एक वेब सर्वर की सर्विस को यूज
करिए एक एप्लीकेशन ओके इफ यू आर एक्सेसिंग
ए वेबसाइट वी यूज ब्राउजर जब भी हम किसी
वेबसाइट को एक्सेस करते तो हम ब्राउजर का
यूज करते हैं तो ब्राउजर भी क्या आपका एक
यूजर एजेंट है ब्राउजर भी आपका एक यूजर
एजेंट है तो इज इट पॉसिबल आवर वेबसाइट इज
ब्राउजर
स्पेसिफिक या वी कैन से दैट विल वेबसाइट
वर्क्स डिफरेंटली ऑन डिफरेंट डिफरेंट
ब्राउजर क्या ये पॉसिबल है कि ये वेबसाइट
है ब्राउजर स्पेसिफिक हो सकती
है या जो वेबसाइट है अलग-अलग ब्राउजर पर
अलग-अलग तरीके से वर्क कर सकती है इज इट
पॉसिबल आप लोग क्या लगता है इज इट
पॉसिबल इज इट पॉसिबल
बताइए आई वांट आंसर फ्रॉम एवरी
बडी बताइए बताइए बताइए
बताइए और कोई मेरे दोस्त यस या
नो
ओके टेक्निकल क्रस यस अखिलेश बिल्कुल हो
सकता है प्रणय यस अमन शेख
यस स्ट्रीम श्यर नहीं ओके और कोई मेरे
दोस्त जो बताइए आप लोगों को क्या लगता है
कि आपकी वेबसाइट ब्राउजर स्पेसिफिक हो
सकती है या नहीं हो शक्ती मैं भी इसका
जवाब दूंगा और काफी डिटेल्स में आपको जवाब
दूंगा शायद किसी ने इस तरीके से इस
कांसेप्ट को क्लियर नहीं किया होगा ओके
बहुत सारे फैक्टर्स
हैं नो आईडिया ओके
मोहम्मद और कोई मेरे
दोस्त
ओके दिस इज वेरी वेरी इंपोर्टेंट
क्वेश्चन कि वेबसाइट इ ब्राउजर स्पेसिफिक
इज इट पॉसिबल यह सवाल है तो इस सवाल का
जवाब हम अभी देखते हैं कि यह पॉसिबल है या
नहीं है दिस इ वेरी वेरी इंपोर्टेंट
क्वेश्चन बहुत लोगों ने यस बोला है और कुछ
लोगों को नहीं
पता यस पर बाकी लोगों सही आईडिया गेस किया
देखिए वेबसाइट ब्राउज स्पे इट पॉसिबल
देखिए इन द एवर इवॉल्विंग वर्ल्ड ऑफ वेब
डेवलपमेंट कप कंपैटिबिलिटी अक्रॉस मल्टीपल
ब्राउजर इज ए क्रुशल
कंसीडरेशन किसी भी वेब डेवलपर के
लिए वेबसाइट की कंपैटिबिलिटी मल्टीपल
ब्राउजर्स के अक्रॉस इज ए बिग चैलेंज कि
वो वेबसाइट अगर मोबाइल पर भी रन करे तोब
भी अच्छे से चलनी चाहिए चाहे वो ब्राव
ब्राउजर प रन करे इंटरनेट एक्सप्लोरर पे
काम करे चाहे सफारी पे चाहे कम पे चाहे वो
firefox.exe
यह सबसे बड़ा स इशू होता है कंपैटिबिलिटी
इशू किसी भी वेब डेवलपर के सामने ओके
नाउ क्रॉस ब्राउजर कंपैटिबिलिटी इज ए
फंडामेंटल एक्सपेक्ट ऑफ वेब डेवलपमेंट
किसी भी वेब डेवलपमेंट का अभी हम एज ए वेब
डेवलपर थोड़ा सा सोच रहे हैं कि उसके बाद
एज ए साइबर सिक्योरिटी प्रोफेशनल हम इस पर
काम करेंगे कि क किसी भी वेब डेवलपमेंट
में क्रॉस ब्राउजर कंपैटिबिलिटी एक
फंडामेंटल एक्सपेक्ट है क्योंकि
इट इज इंपॉसिबल टू प्रिडिक्ट हाउ ए वेब
एप्लीकेशन विल एक्सिस्ट ठीक है यह किसी भी
वेब डेवलपर के द्वारा के के द्वारा
इंपॉसिबल है प्रिडिक्ट करना कि जो आपका
यूजर है या आपकी जो एंप्लॉई है या जो भी
आपकी क्लाइंट है उस वेबसाइट को किस डिवाइस
में किस ब्राउजर की हेल्प से या कैसे
एक्सेस करेंगे यह इंपॉसिबल है इस चीज को
प्रिडिक्ट करना
एंड आल्सो
इंश्योरिटी और एप्लीकेशन फंक्शन स्मूथली
अक्रॉस ऑल मेजर ब्राउजर्स इज नॉट ओनली
अबाउट प्रोवाइड अ सीमलेस यूजर एक्सपीरिंस
बट आल्सो एक्सेसिबिलिटी एंड
अचीविया जो एप्लीकेशन है उसकी जो भी
फंक्शन है सभी मेजर ब्राउजर्स के अंदर
सीमलेसली स्मूथली काम करें नॉट ओनली फॉर
यूजर एक्सपीरियंस जबकि एक्सेसिबिलिटी और
आपका जो बिजनेस गोल है उसको भी अचीव करें
जरूरी नहीं कि यूजर एक्सपीरियंस तो उसमें
अच्छा मिले लेकिन जो उसकी एक्सेसिबिलिटी
है उसको एक्सेस करने की जो फ्रीक्वेंसी है
या जो बिजनेस स्कूल है वे डाउन हो जाओ
नहीं सारे के सारे एक्सपेक्ट क्या होने
चाहिए आपके स्मूथली रन करने चाहिए यह भी
रिस्पांसिबिलिटी किसकी है वेब डेवलपर की
है तो हाउ एवर देयर आर फिर भी कुछ ऐसे
इंस्टेंसस होते हैं जहां पर आपकी
वेबसाइट बिहेव डिफरेंटली और इवन बिकम
एक्सक्लूसिव इन सर्टेन ब्राउजर फिर भी कुछ
ऐसे सरकमस्टेंसस या कुछ इंस्टेंसस होते
हैं जहां पर आपकी जो वेबसाइट है वो
अलग-अलग तरीके से बिहेव करती है दिस
फिनोमेना इज एनटायर पॉसिबल और यह पॉसिबल
है ये थ्रो या तो इंटेंशनली या ड्यू टू
ब्राउजर स्पेसिफिक ओके लेकिन मोस्टली
इंटेंशनली होता है ओके ड्यू टू वेरियस
टेक्निकल एंड डिजाइन रीजस तो लेट्स डाइव
इनटू डिटेल एक्सप्लोरेशन वई एंड हाउ
वेबसाइट कैन बी ब्राउजर स्पेसिफिक कि कोई
भी वेबसाइट कैसे ब्राउजर स्पेसिफिक हो
सकती है नेक्स्ट सवाल है कि ब्राउजर
स्पेसिफिक का मतलब क्या होता है ए वेबसाइट
इज टर्म ब्राउजर स्पेसिफिक वन इट्स
फंक्शनल ले आउट और फीचर्स आर ऑप्टिमाइज्ड
और रिस्ट्रिक्टेड टू सर्टेन वेब ब्राउजर
किसी भी वेबसाइट को हम ब्राउजर स्पेसिफिक
तब बोलेंगे जब उसकी कोई भी फंक्शनल है या
लेआउट है या उसके फीचर्स है वह किसी वेब
ब्राउजर के लिए रिस्ट्रिक्टेड है और किसी
दूसरे वेब ब्राउजर पर वह सारे फंक्शंस वह
सारे लेआउट व सारे फीचर्स स्मूथली वर्क कर
रहे होते हैं तो ट्स आवर मीन ब्राउजर
स्पेसिफिक हाउ वेबसाइट बिकम ब्राउजर
स्पेसिफिक कोई भी वेबसाइट ब्राउजर
स्पेसिफिक कैसे बनती है इसके लिए बहुत
सारे फैक्टर्स हैं जो कंट्रीब्यूट करते
हैं किसी भी वेबसाइट को ब्राउजर स्पेसिफिक
बनने के लिए सबसे पहला जो फैक्टर्स होता
है आपका ब्राउजर स्पेसिफिक फीचर्स ब्राउजर
स्पोर्ट्स डिफरेंट सेट्स ऑफ फीचर्स एपीआई
एंड स्टैंडर्ड्स हर एक ब्राउजर्स के अपने
कुछ फीचर्स होते हैं उसकी एपीआई होती हैं
कुछ स्टैंडर्ड्स होते हैं ओके जिनको
डेवलपर क्या करता है यूज करता है अपनी
फंक्शनल को एडवांस करने ने के लिए और
परफॉर्मेंस को रिजॉल्व करने के लिए फॉर
एग्जांपल द ब्लर इफेक्ट विल वर्क ऑन सफारी
बट नॉट ऑन फायरवर्क्स फॉर एग्जांपल जैसे
कि हम कह सकते हैं कि जो ब्लर इफेक्ट है
वह सफारी पे काम कर रहा है लेकिन
firefox.exe
वेंर प्रीफिक्स आर स्पेसिफिक प्रीफिक्स
दैट आर एडेड टू सीएसएस प्रॉपर्टीज टू
इंश्योर दैट न्यूली इंप्लीमेंटेड और
एक्सपेरिमेंटल सीएसएस प्रॉपर्टीज आर
सपोर्टेड अक्रॉस डिफरेंट वेब ब्राउजर
बेसिकली क्या होता है कि जो वेंर
प्रीफिक्स होते हैं वो ऐसे स्पेसिफिक
प्रीफिक्स होते हैं जिनको सीएसएस
प्रॉपर्टीज के साथ ऐड किया जाता है ओके
खास कर की वो सीएसएस प्रॉपर्टी जो अभी
एक्सपेरिमेंटल फेज में है जिनको एक
स्टैंडर्डाइज फॉर्म में कन्वर्ट नहीं किया
गया है ओके तो दीज प्रीफिक्सेस आर यूज्ड
व्हेन ए न्यू फीचर इज नॉट यट फुली
स्टैंडर्डाइज और वाइडल अडॉप्टेड बाय ऑल
ब्राउजर्स इन प्रीफिक्स को तभी यूज किया
जाता है कि कोई नया फीचर्स आया है लेकिन
उसको सही से स्टैंडर्डाइज नहीं किया गया
है लेकिन बाकी ब्राउजर्स के द्वारा अडॉप्ट
कर लिया गया है और वेरी इजली यूज किया जा
रहा है ओके दैट अलाउ डेवलपर टू
एक्सपेरिमेंट विद द फीचर्स ओके नेक्स्ट ईच
ब्राउजर यूज इट्स ओन प्रीफिक्स हर एक
ब्राउजर अपने खुद के प्रीफिक्स का यूज
करता है जो किसी भी ब्राउजर्स को यह
आइडेंटिफिकेशन
करता है कि यह जो प्रीफिक्स है यह अभी
एक्सपेरिमेंटल फेज में है अभी यह नॉन
स्टैंडर्डाइज है इसका कोई स्टैंडर्डाइज
वर्जन क्रिट नहीं हुआ है वंस द फीचर इज
यूनिवर्सलीस एंड स्टैंडर्डाइज द वेंडर
प्रीफिक्स आर यूजुअली रिमूव्ड
ओके अब व्हाई डू वी यूज वेंडर प्रीफिक्स
बिकॉज क्रॉस ब्राउजर कंपैटिबिलिटी
अवॉइडिंग ब्रेकेज और फीचर टेस्टिंग
क्योंकि अब कोई भी वेबसाइट या कोई भी
एप्लीकेशंस ब्राउजर स्पेसिफिक तो डेवलप
नहीं की जाती
क्योंकि क्लाइंट के केस में नो गारंटी
क्लाइंट सफारी यूज करेगा आप यह नहीं बोल
सकते कि क्लाइंट को कि नहीं हमारी वेबसाइट
या हमारे बिजनेस के सर्विसेस लेने के लिए
आपको कम ब्राउजर चाहिए नो यह आपको यूजर
स्पेसिफिक बनानी होगी तो ट इज द सेकंड
फैक्टर थर्ड फैक्टर है यह एग्जांपल आपका
वेंडर प्रीफिक्स का तो आप खुद से देख लेना
जब आपको स्लाइड मिल जाएगी नाउ जो थर्ड
आपका फैक्टर्स होता है वह आपका यूजर एजेंट
डिटेक्शन होता है और यही आपके केस में काम
करने वाला है जो अभी समझ जाना इसको ध्यान
से सुनना कि यूजर एजेंट डिटेक्शन क्या
होता है यूजर एजेंट डिटेक्शन रेफर टू द
प्रोसेस ऑफ आइडेंट फाइंग द ब्राउजर डिवाइस
एंड ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम ए यूजर इज यूजिंग बाय
एनालाइजिंग द यूजर एजेंट स्ट्रिंग बेसिकली
यूजर एजेंट स्ट्रिंग की हेल्प से आप किसी
भी ब्राउज किसी भी ब्राउजर डिवाइस या
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम को आइडेंटिफिकेशन
यूजर एजेंट स्ट्रिंग है इसको ब्राउजर के
द्वारा वेब सर्वर को भेजा जाता है
एचटीटीपी रिक्वेस्ट हेडर के अंदर सबको समझ
में आ गया होगा कि एचटीटीपी रिक्वेस्ट
हेडर के अंदर एक यूजर एजेंट होता है वहां
पर एक यूजर एजेंट स्ट्रिंग होती है उसमें
इसको भेजा जाता है किसी भी वेब ब्राउजर के
द्वारा वेब सर्वर के पास दैट अलाउ द सर्वर
और क्लाइंट स्क्रिप्ट टू कस्टमाइज कंटेंट
एंड बिहेवियर बेस्ड ऑन द यूजर एनवायरमेंट
जो सर्वर को डिसाइड करने पर
या उसके लिए कोड डिफाइन किया जाता है
जिसके बेस पर डिसाइड किया जाता है कि जो
क्लाइंट है जो ब्राउजर्स है उसको हमें किस
टाइप की स्क्रिप्ट या किस टाइप का कंटेंट
प्रोवाइड करना है अभी ये यूजर एजेंट
स्ट्रिंग क्या होती है द यूजर एजेंट
स्ट्रिंग इज अ पार्ट ऑफ द एसटीटीपी
रिक्वेस्ट हेडर दैट कंटेंस इंफॉर्मेशन
अबाउट द यूजर ब्राउजर ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम
रेंडरिंग इंजन एंड डिवाइस रेंडरिंग इंजन
क्या होता है आई विल एक्सप्लेन जस्ट अ
फाइव मिनट
इट इज एसेंशियली ए वे फॉर द ब्राउजर टू
टेल द वेब सर्वर अबाउट योरसेल्फ फॉर
एग्जांपल मजला 5.0 विज एटी विन 64 एक् 64
एल वेब किट एंड के एचटीएमएल लाइक गको क्रम
सफारी तो इस तरीके से आपका यह यूजर
स्ट्रिंग देखने को मिलती है जब भी आपका
एचटीटीपी हैडर होता है तो एवरीवन गट
क्लियर टिल नाउ कि यूजर एडें डिटेक्शन
होता क्या है
अंजीर ऑफिशियल बोल रहे सर कौन सा कोर्स चल
रहा
है मिस कोड डाल देंगे वो भी वल्नरेबल होती
है अगर उसको सही से फिल्टर नहीं किया जा
रहा होगा ओके और यह अभी दिखाएंगे हम
आपको यह एथिकल हैकिंग कोर्स चल रहा है डे
फोनिक्स एथिकल हैकर एसेंशियल्स और इस तरह
की इंफॉर्मेशन आपको कोई भी नहीं पढ़ा सकता
ओनली डे फोनिक्स ही पढ़ा सकती है आप लोग
लगता कि अभी हम कभी डेवलपर बन जाते और कभी
साइबर सिक्योरिटी एनालिस्ट बन जाते हैं
क्योंकि हमें दोनों की जरूरत है जब तक हम
डेवलपर की तरह नहीं सोचेंगे जब तक हम उसके
तब तक हम साइबर सिक्योरिटी एक्सपर्ट नहीं
बन सकते इट इज ए ट्रुथ
नाउ वई यूजर एजेंट टे इज इंपोर्टेंट क्रॉस
ब्राउजर कंपैटिबिलिटी डिवाइस स्पेसिफिक
एडजस्टमेंट फीचर डिटेक्शन टारगेटिंग
लीगेसी ब्राउजर्स इन इसलिए इन्हीं सभी
कारणों के के लिए हमें क्या है यूजर एजेंट
डिटेक्शन की जरूरत होती है ओके जैसे कि
डिवाइस स्पेसिफिक एडजस्टमेंट की बात करें
बेस्ड ऑन द यूजर एजेंट यू कैन डिटेक्ट
वेदर द यूजर इज ए मोबाइल डिवाइस टैबलेट और
डेस्कटॉप या सर्वर द एप्रोप्राइटिंग
सम फीचर्स मे नॉट बी स्पोर्टेड अक्रॉस ऑल
द ब्राउजर्स एंड यूजर एजेंट डिटेक्शन कैन
हेल्प यू टू लोड अल्टरनेट स्टाइल्स यह
यूजर एजेंट इसमें हेल्प करता है टारगेटिंग
लीगेसी लीगेसी ब्राउजर्स की बात करें तो
ओल्डर ब्राउजर्स होते हैं ऑफर रिक्वायर
स्पेसिफिक फॉल बैक्स और पैचेज टू इंश्योर
दैट ए वेबसाइट वर्क्स तो उस केस में भी
आपका यूजर एजेंट डिटेक्शन है यह
आइडेंटिफिकेशन
आपके सर्वर्स की ओके दीज आर द सम
स्पेसिफिक रीजंस दैट इज व्हाई वी नीड यूजर
एजेंट डिटेक्शंस तो आई होप कि एवरीवन गोट
क्लियर कि थर्ड
फैक्टर क्यों इंपॉर्टेंट है अब आज की
क्लास से रिलेटेड और आपके ब्राउजर
स्पेसिफिक होने का ओके नाउ अभी दिस इज द
एग्जाम यूजर एजेंट एग्जांपल फॉर एग्जांपल
यूजर एजें इंडेक्स ऑफ कम तो कम
firefox.exe
आपका बैक एंड कोड यह जावास्क्रिप्ट में यह
आपका क्लाइंट साइड कोड और दिस इ योर सर्वर
साइड कोड यह पीएचपी में है देखिए क्रोम
इक्वल नॉट इक्वल फाल्स क्रोम य दिस इ य आप
खुद से पढ़ लेना तो चलिए नेक्स्ट नेक्स्ट
फैक्टर
प यह रहा तो फोर्थ फैक्टर आपका है
रेंडरिंग इंजन डिफरेंसेस इन वेब ब्राउजर
रेंडरिंग इंजन इ द सॉफ्टवेयर कंपोनेंट
रिस्पांसिबल फॉर
इंटरप्रेटिव स्क्रिप्ट एंड अदर कंटेंट ऑफ
द वेब पेज इन ए वेब ब्राउजर जो रेंडरिंग
इंजन है वह एक ऐसा सॉफ्टवेयर कंपोनेंट
होता है जो आपके एचटीएमएल सीएसएस
जावास्क्रिप्ट या जो भी वेब पेज के कंटेंट
है उनको इंटरप्रेट करता है उस कोड को
इंटरप्रेट करके विजुअल एलिमेंट में वर्ट
करता है ओके तो डिफरेंट ब्राउजर यूज
डिफरेंट रेंडरिंग इंजन अलग-अलग ब्राउजर
अलग-अलग रेंडरिंग इंजन का यूज करते हैं
व्हिच कैन लीड टू वेरिएशंस इन हाउ ए वेब
पेज इ डिस्प्ले अक्रॉस डिफरेंट ब्राउजर्स
तो अंडरस्टैंडिंग दिस डिफरेंसेस इज क्रुशल
फॉर वेब डेवलपर्स टू इंश्योर क्रॉस
ब्राउजर कंपैटिबिलिटी एंड कंसिस्टेंट यूजर
एक्सपीरियंस तो यह चीज भी इंपॉर्टेंट है
तो फोर्थ फैक्टर यह है जो आपका क्या कर
सकता है
की वेरिएशंस क्रिएट कर सकता ब्राउजर
स्पेसिफिक बना सकता है बट इनमें से बहुत
सारे ऐसे फैक्टर्स हैं जिनके बहुत लिटिल
लिटिल इफेक्ट इफेक्ट होते हैं जो हम अपनी
नेक डाई से आइडेंटिफिकेशन
वेब किट होता है रेंडरिंग इंजन जो सफारी
या सम वर्जंस ऑफ क्रम बिफोर स्विचिंग टू
ब्लिंक उन परे यूज किया जाता था थर्ड वन
है ग को ओनली फ फॉक्स के केस में यूज किया
जाता है ना उसके बाद यूजिंग ट्रिडेंट
ट्रिडेंट ओनली इंटरनेट एक्सप्लोरर के केस
में यूज किया जाता है ब्राउजर यूजिंग एज
एटीएमएल वर्जन ऑफ माइक्रोसॉफ्ट ए बिफोर
वर्जन 79 इसको यूज किया जाता था तो दीज आर
द सम रेंडरिंग इंजंस कौन सा बीलिंक वेब
किट गको और उसके बाद आपका ट्रिडेंट और एज
एचटीएमएल दीज आर सम रेंडरिंग इंजंस और
रेंडरिंग इंजन क्या होते हैं यह आपको पता
चल गया होगा नेक्स्ट जो आपका फिफ्थ फैक्टर
होता है एक्सपेरिमेंटल एंड डेप्रिसिएशन
फीचर क्या होता है एक्सपेरिमेंटल फीचर
रेफर टू न्यू वेब टेक्नोलॉजी और एपीआई दैट
आर स्टिल इन डेवलपमेंट एंड मे नॉट यट टू
बी फुली स्टेबल और स्पोर्टेड अक्रॉस ऑल द
ब्राउजर्स यह भी एक कारण हो सकता है
ब्राउजर स्पेसिफिक होने का क्योंकि कोई एक
नई वेब टेक्नोलॉजी है जो अंडर डेवलपमेंट
है अंडर एक्सपेरिमेंटल फेज में है जो किसी
स्पेसिफिक ब्राउजर पर तो अच्छे से स्पोर्ट
स्पोर्ट करती है बट अदर ब्राउजर्स पर वह
सपोर्ट नहीं करती जिसकी वजह से भी आपको
वेरिएशंस देखने को मिल सकते
हैं सेकंड डेप्रिसिएशन
आई दैट इज नो लंगर
रिकमेंडेशन बिकॉज इट हैज बीन रिप्लेस बाय
ए मोर मॉडर्न और बेटर स्पोर्टेड
अल्टरनेटिव अब डिप्रिड फीचर्स भी आपका एक
कारण हो सकता है क्योंकि हो सकता है कि ये
वेब टेक्नोलॉजी पुरानी होगी या इसके अंदर
कोई वल्नरेबल थी या स सिक्योरिटी फ्लो था
या इससे बेटर चीज आ गई वो जो इसको अभी
फर्द रिकमेंड नहीं किया जाता या उसको
फ्यूचर में हटाया जा सकता है तो दीज आर
आल्सो टू रीजंस या टू फैक्टर्स जिसके भी
थ्रू भी आपका ब्राउजर स्पेसिफिक वेबसाइट
हो सकती है सिक्स्थ जो आपको हमेशा देखने
को मिलता है थर्ड पार्टी इंटीग्रेशंस इन
मॉडर्न वेब डेवलपमेंट थर्ड पार्टी
इंटीग्रेशन आर ए पावरफुल टूल दैट अलाउ
वेबसाइट एंड एप्लीकेशंस टू एक्सटेंड देयर
फंक्शनल बाय कनेक्टिंग विद एक्सटर्नल
सर्विसेस एंड प्लेटफॉर्म मोस्टली आपको य
देखने को मिलता है कि आजकल की जितनी भी
वेबसाइट है उनमें आपको थर्ड पार्टी
इंटीग्रेशन देखने ने को मिलेगा ही मिलेगा
जैसे कि उसकी प्रोसेस को स्ट्रीमलाइन करने
के लिए या यूजर एक्सपीरियंस एहस करने के
लिए या कुछ और एडवांस फीचर्स ऐड करने के
लिए बिना
किसी बिना किसी स्क्रैच बिल्डिंग की है
मतलब आपको शुरू से खुद से डेवलप ना करने
करना पड़े वो आप थर्ड पार्टी टूल्स को
इंटीग्रेट करते हो हाउ एवर इंटीग्रेटिंग
थर्ड पार्टी सर्विसेस इनटू योर वेबसाइट और
वेब एप्लीकेशंस रिक्वायर केयरफुल कं रेशन
ऑफ कंपैटिबिलिटी सिक्योरिटी प्राइवेसी एंड
परफॉर्मेंस तो यह सारी की सारी चीजें मैं
आपको इसलिए बता रहा हूं क्योंकि जब भी आप
वेब से रिलेटेड पन टेस्टिंग कर रहे होते
हैं तो आपको यह फीचर्स ध्यान में होने
चाहिए कि जिनकी वजह से कई बार क्या है कि
ब्राउजर स्पेसिफिक वल्नरेबल भी आपको मिल
सकती है कि आपने तो ओनली एक ही ब्राउजर पर
टेस्ट किया लेकिन दूसरे ब्राउजर पर उसका
वेरिएशन कुछ था या उसका बिहेव अलग था और
हो सकता है कि किसी दूसरे ब्राउजर पर उससे
रिलेटेड किसी भी एक फैक्टर की वजह से
उसमें वल्नरेबल हो ओके तो ये मेरा एक मोटो
आपको बताने का डायरेक्टली इनडायरेक्टली ये
रहा टाइप्स ऑफ थर्ड पार्टी इंटीग्रेशन
पेमेंट गेटवे आपको देखने को मिलता है
ऑथेंटिकेशन सर्विस एनालिटिक्स ट्रैकिंग
टूल्स कस्टमर सपोर्ट एंड चैट सर्विसेस
मार्केटिंग ऑटोमेशन सोशल मीडिया
इंटीग्रेशंस एंड क्लाउड स्टोरेज सर्विसेस
ये सारे आपके थर्ड पार्टी इंटीग्रेशंस हो
सकते हैं आपकी वेबसाइट के अंदर सेवंथ
फैक्टर्स जो आपका हो सकता है डेली ब्रेट
ब्राउजर टारगेटिंग डेवलपर्स मे इंटेंशनली
ऑप्टिमाइज ए वेबसाइट फॉर वन ब्राउजर ड्यू
टू बिजनेस डिसीजन और रिसोर्स कांस्टेंट यह
मैं आपको पहले हम डिस्कस कर चुके कि हां
इंटेंशनली किसी भी वेबसाइट को ब्राउजर
स्पेसिफिक डिजाइन किया जा सकता है
सिक्योरिटी और पॉलिसीज प्राइवेसी पॉलिसीज
के साथ भी हम कर सकते हैं जैसे कि सम
ब्राउजर्स इंप्लीमेंट यूनिक प्राइवेसी और
सिक्योरिटी पॉलिसीज दैट मे प्रिवेंट
सर्टेन वेबसाइट फंक्शन फॉर इंस्टेंस
ब्राउजर्स लाइक फ फॉक्स एंड सफारी ब्लॉक
थर्ड पार्टी कुकी बाय डिफॉल्ट तो
पोटेंशियली ब्रेकिंग फीचर्स लाइक एंबेडेड
कंटेंट और एडवरटाइजिंग स्क्रिप्ट दैट लाई
ऑन द कुकीज तो दीज आर द एट फैक्टर्स जो
आपकी वेबसाइट को ब्राउजर स्पेसिफिक बनाते
हैं और अभी आप लोग मुझे यह बताइए कि
ब्राउजर स्पेसिफिक बना दिया तो मुझे यह
बताइए कि इनमें से कौन सा फैक्टर इसको देख
के बताइए कौन सा फैक्टर हमें इफेक्ट कर
रहा हो
सीएसएस वाला वी कांट डू एनीथिंग थर्ड
पार्टी इंटीग्रेशन अभी तक हम बता नहीं पाए
हैं अब इस चीज को पढ़ के हम यही बता सकते
हैं कि डियर एजेंट यूज योर ओन कोड नेम एज
यूजर एजेंट टू एक्सेस द साइट और यूजर
एजेंट मतलब हो सकता है कि आपकी वेब जो
यूजर एजेंट है वहां पर आपको कोई कोड मेंशन
करना है जिसकी वजह से कोई दूसरा वेब पेज
ओपन हो रहा होगा इज इट
पॉसिबल इज इट पॉसिबल
यह हो सकता
है ओके तो देखिए सो दज आर द केसेस बेस्ड
ऑन दैट वी कैन से दैट इट इज पॉसिबल
ब्राउजर स्पेसिफिक बट बाय सीइंग द वेबसाइट
एज ए नॉर्मल यूजर फ्रॉम फ्रंट साइड वी कैन
नॉट आंसर दिस क्वेश्चंस इससे भी आप एग्री
करते होगे कि अगर आप एक नॉर्मल यूजर्स हो
तो आप इस सवाल का जवाब नहीं दे सकते
क्योंकि दे आर वेरी माइनर चेंजेज ट वी कैन
नॉट सी थ्रो आवर नेक डाई जिनको हम अपनी
आंखों से नहीं दे सकते इस पॉइंट से एग्री
करते हो
एवरीवन एवरीवन इससे एग्री करते हो या नहीं
करते सभी बताइए मुझ से मुझे बताइए
ओके नाउ
अगेन बट नाउ हाउ अभी देखिए यहां पर ठीक आप
लोगों को पता चल गया कि यहां
पर एक फैक्टर है यूजर एजेंट फैक्टर्स है
जो इस वेबसाइट को हो सकता है ब्राउजर
स्पेसिफिक बना रहा हो तो मेरा एक और सवाल
है कि हाउ वी कैन फूल दिस वेबसाइट इनटू
थिंकिंग दैट वी आर एक्सेसिंग दिस वेबसाइट
थ्रू आन कोड नेम हाउ कैन वी डू इट कि अभी
हम एक वेबसाइट को
कैसे फूल करें या मूर्ख बनाए या वेबसाइट
को कैसे यह यकीन दिलाए कि आप जो चाहते हो
जिस कोड नेम से आप वेबसाइट का एक्सेस देना
चाहते हो मैं वही हूं यह चीज मैं कैसे कर
सकता
हूं कैसे कर सकता हूं फॉर ट वी हैव टू मैन
पलेट ट बिटवीन द क्लाइंट एंड सर्वर उसके
लिए हमें क्या करना पड़ेगा जो सर्वर है और
जो आपका क्लाइंट है उसके बीच में जो कुछ
भी हो रहा है उसको मैन पुलेट करना होगा
बताइए यही एक तरीका
है यही एक तरीका है कि मुझे वेबसाइट को यह
सोचने पर मजबूर करना है कि वेबसाइट जो
चाहती है मुझे वही करना है लेकिन अभी मुझे
वेबसाइट को फ फूल बनाना है कि ओके हां मैं
आप जो चाहते हो कि इस कोड कोड नेम का यूज
करके कि आप इस वेब पेज को एक्सेस करते कि
मैं वही हूं जो आप चाहते हो तो यह चीज में
कैसे प्रूव कर सकता हूं वेबसाइट को मुझे
क्या करना पड़ेगा सर्वर और क्लाइंट के बीच
में जो कुछ भी डील हो रहा उसको मैनिपुलेट
करना
होगा बड़े बड़े पैसे हैं आप लोग बड़े
ज्ञानी हो डायरेक्टली टूल्स पर कूद जाते
हो उसके बीच के लॉजिक को कभी समझते नहीं
कि मैं किसी चीज को क्यों यूज कर रहा हूं
ओके
वही तो चीज मैं आपको बोल रहा
हूं देखिए चलो आपको य समझाते हैं कि
क्लाइंट और सर्वर का कम्युनिकेशन फिर से
हम देखते हैं कैसे हो रहा है यह आपका
क्लाइंट है क्लाइंट ने सबसे पहले एक फॉर
एग्जांपल w example.com लिखा तो सबसे पहले
रिक्वेस्ट गई आपकी डीएनएस के पास डीएनएस
ने इस क्यूरी को रिजॉल्व किया आईपी दे
दिया आईपी के बाद क्या हो रहा है थ्री वे
हैंड शेक हुआ जब आपका थ्रीवे हैंड शेक हुआ
कनेक्शन एस्टेब्लिश हो गया देन उसके बाद
क्लाइंट मैसेज सेंड करता है जो भी उसको
चाहिए वेब सर्वर से और सर्वर उसका क्या
करता है रिस्प बैक करता है यह आपका
बेसिकली हाई लेवल पर देखें तो यह
कम्युनिकेशन हो रहा है अभी
नेक्स्ट अभी यह सारी की सारी चीजें जो हो
रही है आपकी वेब ब्राउजर के थ्रू रही है
वेब ब्राउजर एक क्या है आपका यूजर एजेंट
है तो वी कैन नॉट चेंज द यूजर एजेंट आप
मुझे यह बताइए कि वेब ब्राउजर आपका एक
यूजर तो क्या मैं यूजर एजेंट को चेंज कर
सकता हूं अभी कर सकता हूं मैं
बताइए क्या मैं यूजर एजेंट को चेंज कर
सकता
हूं
देखिए इफ वी वांट टू चेंज द यूजर एजेंट
टू समथिंग एल्स ट वी वांट टू चेंज ट वी
वांट टू चेंज वी कैन नॉट डू ट वा बिकॉज
देखिए सस टेकन केयर बाय अवर ब्राउजर इवन
वी कैन नॉट एक्सेस द फंक्शन ब्राउजर देखिए
यूजर एजेंट है आपका ब्राउजर है और जो भी
रिक्वेस्ट भेजी जा रही है जो भी यूजर
एजेंट में वैल्यू सेट की जा रही है वह
सारी सारी किसके द्वारा टेक केयर की जा
रही है आपके ब्राउजर के द्वारा क्या
ब्राउजर की फंक्शन को एक्सेस कर सकते हो
अगला सवाल
क्या आप ब्राउजर की फंक्शनल को एक्सेस कर
सकते
हो क्योंकि मैं तो चाहता हूं कि यूजर
एजेंट को चेंज करना है कि मैं यूजर एजेंट
की वैल्यू को चेंज करके देखना चाहता हूं
कि क्या मैं उसको एक्सेस कर स सकता हूं या
नहीं कर सकता बट अभी यह सारी की सारी
चीजें डील की जा रही है ऑटोमेटिक आपके
firefox.exe
प्रॉक्सी का यूज करेंगे क्या करेंगे हम
प्रॉक्सी का यूज करेंगे अब प्रॉक्सी क्या
होता
है उस केस में हम क्या करेंगे प्रॉक्सी का
यूज करेंगे
नाउ व्हाट इज प्रोक्सी सर्वर ए प्रॉक्सी
सर्वर इज सिस्टम और वी कैन से ट राउटर ट
प्रोवाइड्स ए गेटवे बिटवीन यूजर एंड द
इंटरनेट देयर फॉर इट हेल्प्स प्रिवेंट
साइबर अटैक फ्रॉम एंटरिंग ए प्राइवेट
नेटवर्क यह वह डेफिनेशंस है जो
आपकी ग पे मिलेगी और यह एक रियल डेफिनेशन
है प्रॉक्सी एज ए प्रोस्पेक्टिव ऑफ ए
सिक्योरिटी प्रोफेशनल कि एक ऐसा सिस्टम है
या एक ऐसा राउटर है जो गेटवे की तरह काम
करता है यूजर्स और इंटरनेट के बीच में जो
आपके साइबर आपका जो प्राइवेट नेटवर्क है
उसको साइबर अटैक से बचाता है इट इज अ
सर्वर रेफरड टू एज एन इंटरमीडियरी बिकॉज
इट गोज बिटवीन एंड यूजर्स एंड वेब पेजेस
दे विजिट ऑनलाइन जो आपका यूजर्स है और जो
भी वेब सर्वर्स है या जो भी इंटरनेट उसके
बीच में आपका प्रॉक्सी सेटअप किया जाता है
तो वी कैन से दैट एज ए अटैकर्स इट इज लाइक
ए मिडल मैन अब मैं एज ए साइबर सिक्योरिटी
या एज ए एथिकल हैकर बात करूं तो हमारे लिए
एक मिडल मैन का काम करता है जिससे हम क्या
कर सकते हैं सब कुछ कंट्रोल कर सकते हैं
जिससे हम सब कुछ कंट्रोल कर सकते हैं तो
इसलिए हम क्या करते हैं कि बीच में
प्रॉक्सी सर्वर सेटअप करते हैं जब भी हम
क्या करते हैं क्लाइंट से रिक्वेस्ट
भेजेंगे वह रिक्वेस्ट जाएगी आपके प्रॉक्सी
सर्वर के पास प्रॉक्सी सर्वर आप उस
रिक्वेस्ट को क्या कर सकता है एक्सेस कर
सकता है और एक्सेस करके आप चाहो तो उस
रिक्वेस्ट को मैनिपुलेट भी कर सकते हो
सर्वर से के पास भेजने से पहले उसके बाद
आपने रिक्वेस्ट को मैनिपुलेट किया
मैनिपुलेट करके आपने किसके पास भेज दिया
सर्वर के पास अब सर्वर का रिस्पांस आएगा
आपके पास और व भी किसके थ्रू आएगा आपका
प्रोक्सी के थ्रू आप उस रिस्पांस को भी
क्या कर सकते हो मैनिपुलेट कर सकते हो ठीक
है यह देखने के लिए कि आपका जो सर्वर है
कितना सिक्योर और टेंपर प्रूफ है ओके यह
चेक करने के लिए अदर वाइज आप क्या कर सकते
हो डायरेक्टली उसको क्लाइंट के पास भी बेज
सकते हो तो दोनों ही केस में चाहे आप
रिक्वेस्ट कर रहे हो चाहे आप रिस्पांस
आपको मिल रहा है दोनों ही केस में आप क्या
कर सकते हो मैन पलेट कर सकते हो ओके किसके
थ्रू प्रॉक्सी के थ्रू दैट इज द पावर ऑफ
एथिकल हैकर और प्रॉक्सी के लिए हम यूज
करते हैं दो टूल्स एक तो बबस वूट बबस वूट
और दूसरा ज प्रोक्सी ज प्रोक्सी
आपका किसके द्वारा डिजाइन किया गया है ओपन
सोर्स कम्युनिटी के द्वारा वास्प
कम्युनिटी कम्युनिटी है ओडब्ल्यू
एसडब्ल्यूएसपी ओस ओके जहां पर आप ऑफ 10
वटी पढ़ते हो किसी भी प्रॉक्सी आपका
पोर्ट्स फगर अकेडमी जहां पर ऑटोमेटिक बहुत
सारे आर्टिकल्स बहुत सारे लैब्स आर
अवेलेबल अगर आपको प्रैक्टिस करनी
प्रैक्टिस करनी है तो अभी हमें प्रॉक्सी
सर्वर के लिए दो ऑप्शन है या तो बब सूट
यूज कर सकता हूं या मैं ज प्रॉक्सी यूज कर
सकता हूं अभी अब हम क्या करने वाले इस लैब
में बब स्वीट का यूज करने वाले हैं फिर
फर्द क्लास में मैं आपको ज प्रॉक्सी भी
सिखाऊंगा कि ज प्रॉक्सी को भी हम कैसे
कन्फर कर सकते हैं और कैसे यूज कर सकते
हैं तो आज की क्लास में हम बब स्वीट को
सीखेंगे कंफिल करना इंस्टॉल करना उसके बाद
हम ने क्लास में कंटिन्यू करेंगे कि जो
वेब पेज है उसको कैसे मैनिपुलेट करेंगे
अदर वाइज य आपका टास्क रहेगा कि मैं आज
आपको इंस्टॉलेशन सिखा दूंगा थोड़ा बहुत
आईडिया दे दूंगा कि जय जो आपका बब स्वीट
है कौन-कौन से टैब क्या है थोड़ा सा रफ
आईडिया आपको दे दूंगा सो दैट आप खुद से
प्रैक्टिस करो उस वेब पेज पर हिट एंड
ट्रायल कर करके देखें ओके हिट एंड ट्रायल
और उसके बाद नेक्स्ट क्लास में तो हम
सॉल्व करेंगे ही करेंगे ओके
नो
सर बताइए बताइए पट हैपन किसी का कोई सवाल
है देखिए अभी बब सट क्या होता है बब सूट
इज ए जावा बेस फ्रेमवर्क ट इ डिजाइन फॉर
कंडक्टिंग वेब एप्लीकेशन पेनिट्रेशन
टेस्टिंग इट हैज बिकम द इंडस्ट्री
स्टैंडर्ड टूल फॉर हैंड्स ऑन सिक्योरिटी
असेसमेंट फॉर वेब एंड मोबाइल एप्लीकेशन
इंक्लूडिंग दोज दैट आ रिलाई ऑन एपीआई
बेसिकली आप बब स्ट की हेल्प से वेब
एप्लीकेशन चाहे मोबाइल एप्लीकेशन हो या
चाहे एपीआई हो सभी की पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग
कर सकते हो बब स्वीट कैप्चर द एचटीटीपी
एंड एचटीटीपीएस ट्रैफिक बिटवीन ए ब्राउजर
एंड ए वेब सर्वर एक वेब सर्वर और ब्राउजर
के बीच में क्या करता है एचटीटीपी हो या
आपकी की एटीपीएस ट्रैफिक को दोनों को
कैप्चर करता है और दिस फंडामेंटल
कैपेबिलिटी फॉर्म्स द बैकबोन ऑफ द
फ्रेमवर्क और यही जो वो कैपेबिलिटी है जो
बब स्ट का बैकबोन है रीड की हड्डी है द
एबिलिटी टू इंटरसेप्ट व्यू एंड मॉडिफाई
वेब रिक्वेस्ट बिफोर दे रीज द टारगेट
सर्वर और इवन मैनिपुलेट रिस्पांसस बिफोर
दे आर रिसीवड बाय आवर ब्राउजर मेक्स बब
सूट एज इवैल्युएबल टूल फॉर मैनुअल वेब
एप्लीकेशन टेस्टिंग आप क्या कर सकते हो कि
सर्वर पर रिक्वेस्ट भेजने से पहले ही उस
रिक्वेस्ट को मैनिपुलेट कर सकते हो और जो
सर्वर से जो रिस्पांस आ रहा है वह क्लाइंट
से पहले भेजने से पहले उसको भी मैनिपुलेट
आप कर सकते हो तो इसलिए बब स्ट इज अवेलेबल
इन डिफरेंट एडिशन इसके तीन एडिशंस आपको
देखने को मिलते हैं पहला एडिशन आपका होता
है कम्युनिटी एडिशन बाकी दो एडिशंस आपके
प्रोफेशनल और एंटरप्राइजेस अब प्रोफेशनल
और एंटरप्राइज एडिशंस के लिए आपको लाइसेंस
चाहिए होता है अदर वाइज आपको क्या है कि
क्रैक्ड वर्जन मिल जाते हैं बट आई रिकमेंड
कि अगर आप कोई भी क्रैक वर्जन ट्राई कर
रहे हो तो उससे पहले आपको क्या करना है
क्रैक वर्जन की जो भी फाइल आप क्या करते
हो इंस्टॉल करते हो आपकी मशीन के अंदर
उसको इंस्टॉल करने के बाद उसको वायरस टोटल
पर उसको चेक जरूर कीजिएगा एज जस मैं आपको
डिफेंसिव साइड से बता रहा हूं क्योंकि
बहुत सारी ऐसी क्रैकिंग फाइल्स है जो आपके
सिस्टम में मालवेयर ले आती है जिनकी वजह
से बहुत सारे लोगों को लॉस हुआ है बहुत
सारे लोगों के सिस्टम कंप्रोमाइज हो गए
हैं ओके क्योंकि ये आपको कैसे पता चलेगा
क्योंकि जो जितनी भी एमबी की फाइल होगी
उसको 100 एबी तक स्पोर्ट करता आपका वायरस
टोटल तो उस फाइल में नंबर ऑफ थ्रेड
डिटेक्ट करेगा कि कितने एंटीवायरस ने उसको
डिटेक्ट किया है जब उनकी रिपोर्ट पढ़ोगे
तो आपको पता चल जाए है कि अलग-अलग यूजर्स
ने उन परे रिकमेंडेशंस दिए हैं अलग-अलग
यूजर्स ने उन्होंने उनमें कमेंट किए हैं
कि यह जो वर्जन है यह एक ट्रोजन है एक यह
मालवेयर है तो बी अवेयर जब तक आपको बेस्ट
क्रैक वर्जन नहीं मिल जाता तो अपनी मशीन
पर ट्राई मत कीजिए मैं आपको रिकमेंड
करूंगा ओके हम क्या करते हैं डायरेक्टली
गट अप से उठाते हैं या मीडियम से उठाते
हैं अब लोग क्या करते हैं जो प्रोफेशनल्स
है वो उनमें ट्रोजन या मालवे इंस्टॉल करके
रख देते हैं क्योंकि फ्री की चीज है और
फ्री की चीज में ट्रोजन मालवेयर आपके
सिस्टम को अफेक्ट कर सकता है और आज हम
देखने वाले कम्युनिटी एडिशंस बिकॉज
प्रोफेशनल को मैं
आपको शो नहीं कर सकता ड्यू टू ट पॉलिसीज
हम स्ट्राइक कर जाएंगे तो इसलिए प्रोफेशनल
वर्जन को हम यूज नहीं करने वाले मैं आपको
कम्युनिटी एडिशन दिखा दूंगा और एक और चीज
है अगर आपको बब सट को यूज करना सीखना है
तो बग बाउंट की क्लास में एक क्लास हुई थी
बब स्वीट के ऊपर जो अराउंड 1 आवर 42 मिनट
की होगी अराउंड या उससे भी ज्यादा तो उसको
भी देख सकते हो वहां पर नितेश सर ने
एक्सप्लेन किया था कि बब स्वीट को कैसे
यूज किया जाता है तो मैं भी एक्सप्लेन
करूंगा बेसिक लेवल पर और फिर हम
डायरेक्टली अपनी क्लासेस में यूज करेंगे
और जप प्रॉक्सी को मैं डिटेल में
एक्सप्लेन करूंगा क्योंकि ज प्रोक्सी के
ऊपर कोई भी वीडियोस अवेलेबल नहीं है हमारे
चैनल के ऊपर ओके
मान सिंह का क्वेश्चन सर आई नो क्वेश्चन
ओके सो बड़ य के थ्रू कैप्चर ट्रैफिक को
डिकोड कर सकते हैं मीस वीडियो देखी है कोई
सिंपली एक्सप्लेन नहीं मिली अभी वा सा की
जब बात आएगी तो मैं आपको एक्सप्लेन कर
दूंगा ओके डोंट वरी इस सवाल का जवाब अभी
क्या है कि कुछ लोग अभी इसमें क्या है कि
पॉसिबिलिटी भी है डिकोड हो जाते हैं
बट उसके लिए आपको एक अच्छी नॉलेज होनी
चाहिए
ओके तो अभी हम चलते हैं
नेक्स्ट कि प्रैक्टिकली कैसे इंस्टॉल
इंस्टॉल करते हैं बब स्वीट को लेकिन बाय
डिफॉल्ट कम्युनिटी एडिशन आपके चाहे पैट ओस
हो चाहे आपका लिनक्स ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम हो
दोनों में इंस्टॉल आता है लेकिन मैं आपको
यूज करके दिखाता हूं कि कैसे हम उसको यूज
कर कर सकते ओके कैसे हम उसको कन्फर कर
सकते हैं तो चलिए हम अपनी स्क्रीन पर चलते
हैं और सीखते हैं अगर आपको प्रॉक्सी
सर्विस रिलेटेड कोई आर्टिकल चाहिए कि
प्रोक्सी सर्वर होता क्या है कैसे काम
करता है तो उ रिलेटेड आर्टिकल य है मेरे
पास आप देख सकते हो
यहा एक य आर्टिकल
है नाउ गो बैक टू अवर
मशीन तो अभी तक हम यहां पर कुछ भी नहीं
मिला तो डरबस्टर के थ्रू तो हम इसको क्या
कर देते हैं स्टॉप कर देते हैं जस्ट इक्सड
पीएपी है इंक्स ड पीएपी कॉपी यूआरएल हमें
यहां पर कुछ मिलता है तो देखते हैं एक
बार यस इक्सड पीएपी भी यही है कुछ अलग
नहीं है तो इक्सड पीएपी में भी हमें कुछ
नहीं मिला ओके तो इसको हम क्लोज कर देते
हैं अननेसेसरी सिस्टम की पावर को वेस्ट
नहीं करते हैं तो आप सबसे पहले क्या करना
है कि कन्फर करना है तो आप कैसे यूज कर
सकते हो गो टू योर दिस टैब यहां पर आप
सर्च कर लीजिए किसको बब स्वीट आप क्या
करोगे बर्ब बाय डिफॉल्ट मिलता है य आपका
बब सूट क्लिक करना इस
परे यह आपका बब सूट कम्युनिटी एडिस है और
डायरेक्टली आपको नेक्स्ट नेक्स्ट नेक्स्ट
करना है ओके मैं आपको दिखा देता हूं फिर
भी
मेरे पास एक ट्रोजन फ्री आप डायरेक्टली
विंडो प इंस्टॉल कर सकते हो उसमें एक
ट्रोजन फ्री है मेरे पास उसमें एक
इंडिकेटर दिखाता बट वो उससे कोई इफेक्ट
नहीं होता क्योंकि उससे आपकी मशीन पर कोई
इफेक्ट नहीं होता क्योंकि वह फॉल्स
पॉजिटिव फॉल्स रिजल्ट शो करता वाय टोटल
ओनली एक ही वायर शो करता है उसमें बाकी
मेरे पास जो है वो अच्छा है ओल्ड है बट
गोल्ड
है तो यह आपका आपको सिंपली क्या करना है
क्लिक ऑन नेक्स्ट देन स्टार्ट बब सूट ओके
स्टार्ट बब स्वीट
ना यह हमारा बप स्वीट का डैशबोर्ड है यह
आपका जो क्या होता है यह आपका मॉड्यूल बार
है यह आपका मेन मॉड्यूल बार है इसके अंदर
बहुत सार डैशबोर्ड टारगेट प्रॉक्सी
इंट्रूडर रिपीटर कोलैबोरेटर सीक्वेंसर
डिकोडर कंपेरर लगर ऑर्गेनाइजर एक्सटें
और लर्न यह बहुत सारे ऑप्शन होते हैं यह
आपका मॉड्यूस बार है मेन मॉडल्स बार है
इसके भी सब टाप्स होते हैं और जिसके सब
टेप्स आपको नीचे देखने को मिल डैशबोर्ड
जैसे मैंने क्लिक किया टारगेट टारगेट के
भी सब टेप्स है तो डायरेक्टली इसके नीचे
देखने को मिलते हैं साइट मैप स्कोप और इशू
डेफिनेशन अभी टारगेट टैब क्या होता है
प्रोक्सी टैब क्या होता है अभी हम जो
कंसर्न है वो प्रोक्सी टैब से है लेकिन
इससे पहले हमें क्या करना है इसको सेट
करना है तो गो टू प्रॉक्सी टैब प्रॉक्सी
सेटिंग और प्रोक्सी सेटिंग में आपको क्या
करना है प्रॉक्सी और प्रॉक्सी लिनर यहां
पर आपको क्या जब भी ऑन करोगे बाय डिफॉल्ट
क्या मिलेगा सेट मिलेगा अदर वाइज खुद से
भी एक और प्रॉक्सी आप ऐड कर सकते हो यहां
पे अभी सेट है मेरा तो ये क्या इंटरफेस
मेरा क्या है 127 0.0.1
8808 उसके बाद यह रहा देन हमें नेक्स्ट
क्या चीज करनी है अपने जो हमारा ब्राउजर
है जो मेरा ये firefox.exe
गो टू योर फ फॉक्स और हमें इससे पहले काम
एक काम करना है एक एक्सटेंशन एक बोल सकते
हैं हम एक्सटेंशन या प्लगइन हमें डाउनलोड
करना है तो उस प्लग इन का नाम आपका
फायरफॉक्स पक्सी फॉक्सी
प्रोक्सी फॉक्सी एंड प्रॉक्सी आपको सर्च
करना है हिट एंटर और य यह आपका
firefox.exe
टू फायरफॉक्स अभी मैं रिमूव नहीं करना अभी
ऐड करना तो आपको क्या करना आपके केस में
आएगा ड टू फयर फॉक्स अभी हम गो टू दिस टैप
कट कर देते हैं देन गो टू दिस टप आपको इस
तरीके से आपका एक्सटेंशन देखने को मिलेगा
फक्सी प्रोक्सी अभी मुझे टैब के अंदर सेट
कैसे करना मैं आपको दिखा दं गो टू
ऑप्शन नाउ ऑप्शन के अंदर आपको क्या करना
है गो टू प्रोक्सी और यहां पर आपको क्या
करना ऐड करना है जैसे आप ऐड करोगे यहां पर
टाइटल लिख सकते हो उसके बाद टाइप क्या है
एचटीटीपी देन उसके बाद कलर अकॉर्डिंग ली
आप क्या कर सकते हो सेट कर सकते हो देन
होस्ट नेम क्या आपका
17.0.1 या जो भी आपका होस्ट नेम आईपी
एड्रेस है कौन सा पोर्ट नंबर आप यूज कर
रहे हो अगर यूजर नेम और पासवर्ड ही आप सेट
करना चाहते हो वो भी सेट कर सकते हो देन
आपको सिंपली क्या करना है सेव करना है अभी
मुझे सेव करने की जरूरत नहीं है तो अभी हम
गो बैक कर देते हैं यहां पे सेट हो जाएगा
जैसे मेरा बब स्ट सेट है इसमें देखिए बब
स्वीट एचटीटीपी होस्ट नेम यह है 8080 बस
जस्ट इतना ही है और सेव कर रखा है अभी मैं
इसको क्या कर देता हूं क्लोज कर देता हूं
विंडो को जब भी मुझे क्या करना होगा अभी
अपने प्रॉक्सी का यूज करना है तो मैं कैसे
करूंगा देखिए यह रिक्वेस्ट है तो मुझे
क्या करना होगा देख यह रहा बब स्वीट इस पर
क्लिक करना है जो आपने टाइटल सेव किया था
ऑन हो गया और साथ में पलल में ये रहा आपका
बब स्वीट कम्युनिटी एडिशन ऑन हो चाए
सेटिंग है इसको क्लोज कर देते हैं दिस इ
बट प्रॉक्सी अब मुझे क्या करना है गो टू
योर इंटरसेप्ट अभी मैं इंटरसेप्ट टैब ऑफ
कर रहा हूं अभी यहां पर कुछ ऑप्शन देख ना
इंटरसेप्ट ऑन और ऑफ अगर आप ऑन करोगे तो
जैसे ही आपकी जो भी वेब रिक्वेस्ट है जब
भी आप क्या कर कोई भी वेब रिक्वेस्ट करोगे
तो वो होल्ड बैक हो जाएगी हेल्ड बैक मतलब
कि आपके सर्वर के पास नहीं जाए क्योंकि
इंटरसेप्ट ऑन है आप हर एक रिक्वेस्ट को
क्या कर सकते हो देख सकते हो एनालाइज कर
सकते हो उसको किसी दूसरे जो मॉड्यूस है
टारगेट मॉड्यूल रिपीटर्स है या कोलबेट है
सीक्वेंसर है या इंट्रूडर है उनके अंदर
भेज सकते हो उस रिक्वेस्ट को देन आप उस
परे डिसीजन ले सकते हो ओके कि मुझे इसको
रिक्वेस्ट को फॉरवर्ड करना है या ड्रॉप
करना है तो ये सार डिसीजन आपके हाथ में हो
जाता है अगर आप इंटरसेप्ट को ऑफ करते हो
तो उस केस में क्या होता है आप गो टू
टारगेट साइट मैप अब साइट मैप में आप देख
सकते हो सारी डिटेल्स जो भी ट्रैफिक आपका
फ्लो कर रहा है आपके वेब ब्राउजर के थ्रू
जो भी रिक्वेस्ट चाहे वो
की यहां पर एक्टिविटी में देखने में फॉर
एग्जांपल अभी मैं इसको क्या करता
हूं रिफ्रेश करता हूं हिट एंटर देखिए अभी
मैं यह रहा यह देखिए यह ओनली इसने शो कर
दिया साइट मैप है क्योंकि एक ही वेबसाइट
है यह देखिए गेट एटीपी ओके अभी एक और इस
क्योंकि अभी ये एचटीटीपी है मुझे एचटीटीपी
साइट को भी इसके थ्रू पास करना है अब ये
देखो गेट मेथड है ये इसका रिक्वेस्ट है ये
रिक्वेस्ट हेडर है जिसमें देखिए एटीटीपी
ये दिस इज योर यूजर एजेंट मजला 5.0
आपका होता है बी आर यू
पी यह
रहा बब स्वीट या कुछ ऐसे करके हम जाते
हैं ओके एक यह रहा दिस इज नाउ नाउ
कम्युनिटी एडिशन सर्टिफिकेट डाउनलोड करने
के लिए मुझे क्या करना है बब स्वीट
नाउ समथिंग एल्स आईम मिसिंग समथिंग तो
मुझे एक काम करना पड़ेगा चलो
हम एक काम करते हैं यह तो है ही अभी आवर
एसिस्टिंग मशीन इज रनिंग नाउ नाउ नाउ
ओके मैं भूल गया
हूं या मे भी आप सही कह रहे होगे मुझसे हो
गई होगी के
ओके नाउ ना ओके ओके ओके मैं स्पेलिंग गलत
लिख रहा हू या
राइट यह रहा ओके गट इट आपको क्या करना है
डाउनलोड सी सर्टिफिकेट अभी सर्टिफ डडी आर
आपका डाउनलोड हो गया डाउनलोड डायरेक्टरी
के अंदर देन आपको नेक्स्ट स्टेप आपका क्या
रहेगा गो टू सेटिंग सेट के अंदर आपको क्या
करना है दिस सेटिंग टैब और यहां पर आपको
क्या करना अभी जूम कर देता हूं आपको य पर
सर्टिफिकेट सर्च करना
है यह रहा सर्टिफिकेट व्यू
सर्टिफिकेट देन आपको यहां पर क्या करना है
इंपोर्ट इंपोर्ट और डाउनलोड में य रहा
सर्टिफिकेट और ओपन सिंपली ओपन करना है देन
देखो ट्रस्ट दिस सी
ओके ट्रस्ट कर देना नाउ ओके नाउ
ओके ओके और ओके अभी सक्सेसफुली हमने
सर्टिफिकेट को ऐड कर लिया फिर से अगर मैं
देखना चाहता हूं व्यू सर्टिफिकेट देन आपको
देखने को मिलेगा ये सर्टिफिकेट आपको देखने
को मिलेगा ट्रस्टेड सीए सर्टिफिकेट नाउ
नाउ नाउ सबसे लास्ट में देखने को मिलेगा
बब सूट
का नहीं नहीं देखने को मिलेगा एक मिनट
ये रहा प स्गर सी आपको देखने को मिल रहा
है प स्गर सी आपको देखने को मिल रहा है तो
सर्टिफिकेट सक्सेसफुली ऐड हो गया अभी जो
भी मेरा एचटीटीपीएस ट्रैफिक है वो भी इसके
थ्रू जा सकता है कैसे अभी मैं दिखाता हूं
कि अभी यह ओपन किया देखिए यहां पर जस्ट
मैंने ओपन ही किया यहां पर सारा यह रहा
https.com यह भी आ गया देन अगर मैं इसको
क्या करता हूं यह रहा स्टॉप अभी मिनिमाइज
करते थोड़ा सा दिस इज अवर
यह रहा अभ आपका क्या है साइट मैप है अब
साइट मैप में सब कुछ देख जैसे मैं
[संगीत]
google.com अब जैसे यहां पर लिक किया यह
भी आपको देखने को मिलेगा
ये सारी की सारी रिक्वेस्ट आपका कैप्चर की
जा रही है किसके अंदर बब सूट के अंदर
देखिए trm.com देन देन देन इट इज ओपनिंग
बिकॉज इट विल टेक टाइम बट जितने भी वेब
ट्रैफिक
आपका ट्रेवल कर रहा है आपके ब्राउजर के
थ्रू या ब्राउजर से वो सारा सारा आप
कैप्चर कर पा रहे हो ओके वो सारा सारा आप
क्या कर पा रहे हो कैप्चर कर पा रहे हो
अभी देखिए इट विल ओके स्टार्टेड नाउ यहां
भी देख सकते हो आप
youtube0 रहा
youtube0 देखिए यहां पर यहां पर होस्ट नेम
कौन सा मेथड यूज किया जा रहा है गेट मेथड
या पोस्ट मेथड यहां पर यूआरएल है यूआरएल
आपको देखना है फुल यूआरएल अगर यूआरएल में
पैरामीटर्स है तो आप पैरामीटर्स भी देख
सकते हो टिक का अ टिक की हेल्प से जहां पर
टिक हुआ है यह आपका पैरामीटर इंफॉर्मेशन
शो करता है स्टेटस कोड में आपको देखने को
मिल रहा है कि 200 ओके स्टेटस है 32 है
403 आपको पता होना चाहिए 200 का मतलब आपका
सक्सेसफुल है ओके अगर 302 है रीडायरेक्ट
है ये आपको पता होना चाहिए बाकी लेंथ है
और एमआई एमई टाइप अभी टाइटल क्या
अभी मुझे किसी भी पर्टिकुलर वेबसाइट को
टारगेट करना होता है या पर्टिकुलर मेरा एक
टारगेट होता है अब यह सारा का सारा
ट्रैफिक मुझे अननेसेसरी कंफ्यूज करता है
तो इस कंफ्यूजन से बचने के लिए हम क्या कर
सकते हैं यहां पर दो ऑप्शन यूज कर सकते
हैं हम अपना स्कोप ऐड कर सकते हैं कि
पर्टिकुलर टारगेट ही होना चाहिए मेरा
टारगेट यह है इसको मैं अपने स्कोप में ऐड
कर सकता हूं दो तरीके हैं कैसे ऐड कर सकता
हूं एक तो जैसे कि राइट क्लिक किया ड टू
स्कोप कर सकते हैं ओके ऐड टू स्कोप यह बोल
रहा है अगर आपको देख यू हैव एडेड एन आइटम
टू टारगेट स्कोप डू यू वांट ब प्रॉक्सी टू
स्टॉप सेंडिंग आउट ऑफ स्कोप आइटम्स ओके यस
मैंने यहां पर यस किया अभी मैंने अपने
स्कोप में ऐड कर दिया देखो यहां पर जब मैं
चेक करूंगा स्कोप टैब के अंदर मुझे आप
स्कोप में क्या दिखेगा http1 10.45 104
देखिए ये मेरा स्कोप ऐड हो गया अदर वाइज
मैंड ऐड करके भी य मैनुअली ऐड कर सकता हूं
अभ यहां पर प्रीफिक्स फुल यूआरएल देन तो
दो तरीके से हम ऐड कर सकते हैं देन साइट
मैप गो टू साइट मैप अभी यहां पर इशू क्या
है कि यहां पर ये चीजें हैं कि फिर भी
आपका वेब ट्रैफिक इसमें फॉलो कर रहा है
अभी मैं चाहता हूं कि यहां पर जो भी
ट्रैफिक दिखे वो ओनली ऐड स्कोप आइटम का ही
दिखे तो उस केस में हम क्या करते हैं यहां
पर सेट माय फिल्टर का भी यूज क्लिक करेंगे
यहां पर ये देखिए शो ओनली इन स्कोप आइटम
यहां पर क्लिक करना है और इसको अनटिक कर
दो हाइड नॉट फाउंड आ आइटम्स मतलब आपको जो
आइटम्स नहीं मिले उनको हाइड नहीं करना है
क्योंकि उनको भी हम टेस्ट कर सकते हैं और
सिंपली अप्लाई करना है अप्लाई हो गया तो
अभी ओनली ड स्कोप आइटम ही यहां पर आएंगे
अब फरदर चाहे आप
[संगीत]
googlegroups.com की वेबसाइट के अंदर तो
जिनके बारे में क्या कर सकते हो आप पढ़
सकते हो डिस्क्रिप्शन ले सकते हो उनकी
रेडिएशंस ले सकते हो रेफरेंसेस ले सकते हो
प्रोक्सी टैब में इंटरसेप्ट ऑन कर सकते हो
आप अभी मैं इंटरसेप्ट ऑन करूंगा जैसे
मैंने इंटरसेप्ट ऑन किया और फॉर एग्जांपल
जस्ट मैंने क्या किया यह रहा अकाउंट इसको
मैं फिर से क्या करता हूं यह रहा और जैसे
इंटरसेप्ट ऑन किया देखो यह रहा अभी भी ये
यहां
पर लोड ही कर रहा है क्योंकि अभी लोड कर
रहा है लेकिन हमारे पास क्या ये रहा देखो
रिक्वेस्ट गेट रिक्वेस्ट
गेट रिक्वेस्ट है यह आपकी रिक्वेस्ट है
यहां पर गेट एचटीटीपी रिक्वेस्ट यह आपका
होस्ट है देखिए यहां पर अभी मैं चाहूं तो
इसको ड्रॉप भी कर सकता हूं या फॉरवर्ड कर
सकता हूं या रिपीटर के अंदर ऐड कर सकता
हूं या इंट्रोड के अंदर ऐड कर सकता हूं
अभी हम यहां पर है ओके तो यह देखिए यह
रिक्वेस्ट आपकी अभी मैं चाह तो इसका
रिस्पांस यही पर देख सकते इसका रिस्पांस
क्या आएगा इसके लिए मैं क्या कर सकता हूं
राइट
क्लिक राइट क्लिक डू नॉट डू इंटरसेप्ट
रिक्वेस्ट रिस्पांस टू दिस रिक्वेस्ट
रिस्पांस टू दिस रिक्वेस्ट ओके और जैसे
इसको क्या करूंगा फॉरवर्ड यह इसका रिस्प य
भी क्या है रिक्वेस्ट ही है अभी भी आपकी
रिक्वेस्ट है
फॉरवर्ड फॉरवर्ड देखिए अभी
फॉरवर्ड यह आपका फिर भी फॉरवर्ड जब भी
रिस्पांस आएगा आपको पता चल जाएगा यह
रहा यह रहा रिक्वें य आपको रिस्पांस देखने
को मिल रहा ये रिस्पांस इसका डियर एजेंट
योर कोड यूज योर ड कोड नेम लाइक दैट इस
तरीके से आप इसका रिस्पांस भी दे सकते हो
तो दिस इज द बेसिक यूज केस ऑफ द बब स्वीट
इस तरीके से आप इसको क्या कर सकते हो
कन्फर कर सकते हो अपने फॉक्सी प्रोक्सी के
साथ यह कुछ बेसिक टैब्स है जो मैंने आपको
बता दिया क्योंकि यह बग बाउंट अगर आप करते
हो तो उस केस में आपको यह सारे टैब मालूम
होने चाहिए सारे टैब की आपको नॉलेज होनी
चाहिए सीक्वेंसर को कैसे यूज करना है
डिकोडर को कैसे यूज करना है रिपीटर को
कैसे यूज करना है इंट्रोड को कैसे यूज़
करना है फर्द कुछ जितने भी टाप्स की
रिक्वायरमेंट हम अपनी अभी क्लास में यूज
करेंगे या नेक्स्ट क्लास में यूज़ करेंगे
हमारे कोर्स स्पेसिफिक अगर आपको डिटेल्स
में पढ़ना है तो नितेश सर ने बग बाउंट
सीरीज में बब
स्वीट के बारे में डिटेल्स एक्सप्लेन किया
है फिर भी आप लोगों को अगर डिटेल्स कोर्स
चाहिए बब स्वीट के ऊपर बट इस कोर्स में तो
हम डिलीवर नहीं कर सकते फिर जैसे कोर्स
कंप्लीट हो जाएगा तो बब स्वीट के ऊपर हम
डिटेल्स वीडियो लेके आ सकते हैं बट अभी के
लिए आई एम सॉरी बब स्वीट पे डिटेल वीडियो
हम नहीं बना सकते हां यूज हम करते रहेंगे
जब भी हम यूज करेंगे तो आपको एक्सप्लेन कर
दूंगा इस स्टेप में हमने क्या परफॉर्म
किया इस स्टेप में हमने क्या परफॉर्म किया
क्योंकि बब स्वीट एक काफी इंटरेस्टिंग टूल
है अगर आपके पास प्रो वर्जन है तो इट इज
वेरी वेरी इंटरेस्टिंग टूल आपको इसके
ट्रिक्स टैक्टिक्स आनी चाहिए आपको यूज
करना आना चाहिए क्योंकि यह काफी हेल्पफुल
होता है वेब एप्लीकेशन पेंटेस्टिंग के केस
में या बग बाउंट में इट इज वेरी वेरी वेरी
हेल्पफुल ओके तो आज का सेशन इतना ही रहेगा
हमारा तो
ओके तो अभी मैं अभी के लिए इसको क्या कर
देता हूं मैं क्लोज कर देता हूं
स्टॉप यस
एग्जिट अभ इसके लिए इसको क्या करते हम
क्लोज
लोज इसको हम क्या करते हैं यह रहा इसको
डिसेबल कर देते हैं इस तरीके से हमारा
क्लोज हो गया और आज के लिए हम लैब को
टर्मिनेट करते हैं अभी आपका टास्क है आपको
क्या करना है टर्मिनेट
लैब अभी आपका टास्क है कि फर्द आपने जो
रिक्वेस्ट देखी थी जो वेब पेज देखा था उस
परे आपको हिंट मिल गया आपको आईडिया है
मुझे यूजर एजेंट को ही चेक करना है तो ऐसा
हम क्या कर सकते हैं
कि जो वेब पेज हमें चाहिए वह हमें मिल जाए
थ्रू बब स्वीट ओके यह आपका टास्क है आप
इसको खुद से करके देखिए नेक्स्ट क्लास में
हम इसमें एक्सप्लेन कर क्योंकि इसमें बहुत
सारे मिक्स अप है क्योंकि ये जो एक यह लैब
ऐसी लैब है जिसमें क्या है कि बहुत सारे
कांसेप्ट हैं कि वेब एप्लीकेशन पे हमें
कुछ ऐसी इंफॉर्मेशन मिलेगी जो आपके एफटीपी
में हेल्प करेगी उसके बाद एफटीपी में कोई
ऐसी इंफॉर्मेशन मिलेगी जो आपको एसएसए में
हेल्प करेगी और इसमें हम स्टेग्रिड
ा फी अभी हमने लास्ट क्लास में इजी वे में
देखा था थोड़ी सी इजी देखी थी बट यहां पर
क्या है स्टेग्रिड
देखने को मिलेगी तो यह लैब इजी लैब नहीं
है नाम की इजी है बट इसमें मल्टीपल
स्टेप्स हैं यहां पर आपको मल्टीपल
टेक्निक्स देखने को मिलेंगी मल्टीपल
टेक्निक सीखने को मिलेंगी ओके तो आज की
क्लास से रिलेटेड अभी कोई डाउट हो आप
मुझसे पूछ सकते हो और बाकी नेक्स्ट क्लास
हम संडे को लेंगे और संडे को हम क्या
करेंगे फिर फर्द इस सीटीएफ को कंप्लीट
करेंगे
बताइए स्टिल एनी वन एनी डाउट
किसी का कोई
सवाल और एक चीज का मैं प्रॉमिस करता हूं
अगर इस क्लास में अगर 2930 की स्ट्रेंथ
रही ना कि हम सर इतने ही लाइव आएंगे इससे
ज्यादा लाइव नहीं आएंगे तो लिनेक्स प्लीज
एस्केलेशन के बाद आई प्रॉमिस में क्लास
इसको कोर्स को बंद कर दूंगा
सच में कर दूंगा
मैं फिर आपको जहां से मजा आता है सीखने
में वहीं से
सीखना पेड रख दूंगा जिसको सीखना है पैसे
दो और आओ अदर वाइज मुझे फर्क नहीं
पड़ेगा आप लोगों के लिए मैं क्लास रेडी
करता हूं सीटीएफ को इतने बेटर वे में
डिलीवर करता हूं कि यहां पर मैं चाहता
सीटीएफ को एक क्लास में फिनिश कर देता और
आपके सामने बस टूल्स परफॉर्म करके दिखा बट
मैंने यहां पर आप लोगों के लिए कांसेप्ट
रेडी किया है दो दिन में जाके कांसेप्ट
रेडी हुआ है आप लोगों कांसेप्ट एक पीपीटी
के थ्रू में आपको एक्सप्लेन करता हूं आप
मेरे को टेंडेंसी इतनी देते
हो और आईम वेरी सीरियस पर्टिकुलर दिस थिंग
कि मैं मुझे क्या करना अभी बंद कर सकता
हूं इसको मैं
क्योंकि आप लोग डिजर्व नहीं
करते इंडिया में फ्री की चीजें देते हो ना
तो लोगों बर्दाश्त नहीं
होती बाहर वालों के पास पैसे बहुत होते
हैं जितना पैसा मांगे उतने पैसे पर उनको
कोस्ट डिलीवरी चाहिए व ले लेंगे हमारे
वालो के पास चीजें फ्री में दो तब भी उनको
उसको इंपॉर्टेंस नहीं है
ओके बाय बाय सेशन को एंड करते हैं
एंड सी यू फॉर नेक्स्ट सेशन
बाय बाय टेक केयर गुड नाइट एंड मिलते हैं
फिर नेक्स्ट सेशन में बाय बाय